la justicia de bolivia en pone cuatro
meses sino seis como pidió la fiscalía
de prisión preventiva a la ex presidenta
interina jeanine áñez acusada de
sedición y terrorismo por los hechos que
condujeron a la salida anticipada del ex
mandatario evo morales- a finales de
2019 áñez detenida desde la madrugada
del sábado acusó al partido izquierdista
más de su persecución como hemos
denunciado el más decidido y el sistema
judicial obedece me envían cuatro meses
detenida para esperar un juicio por un
golpe que nunca ocurrió
desde aquí llamó a bolivia a tener fe y
esperanza un día entre todos
levantaremos una bolivia mejor el ex
ministro de justicia álvaro coimbra y el
antiguo responsable de energía rodrigo
guzmán también permanecerán en la cárcel
durante cuatro meses una decisión que
divide al país que prepara marchas
masivas tanto a favor como en contra de
la medida
los partidarios de agnès denuncian un
ajuste de cuentas político
del gobierno autocrático presidido por
luis arse y conducido políticamente por
evo morales- de ejercitar terrorismo de
estado en el conjunto de la sociedad
mientras que las víctimas del golpe de
estado hablan de justicia ahora yo pido
justicia que se haga justicia
martín 18 años al menos 36 personas
fallecieron durante la crisis política y
social que atravesó el país a finales de
2019 cuando los partidarios del ex
presidente morales depuesto por la
cúpula militar tras acusaciones de
fraude electoral se enfrentaron a las
fuerzas de seguridad una violencia por
la que ahora la justicia boliviana pide
aclarar responsabilidades